was geht hier seine maxime ich bin
zusammen mit luca in wales am strand
hier wie im fall hat der liebe der sich
eine coole change überlegt wie wir heute
machen werden und zwar wie ihr bisschen
wer schon länger befreundet und wir
werden jetzt einfach mal herausfinden
wie viel wir so über den anderen wissen
so ein paar bestimmte fragen fünf stück
an der zahl haben wir uns ausgedacht und
die werden uns jetzt gegenseitig stellen
und klug haben wir auch was richtig
lustige sechsmal aus und der
beschreibung also ich würd sagen oder
wache wieder schnitt stück nachbestellt
verknüpft
naja frage stellen ja nenne meine top 3
schuhmarken okay nike ist diese drei
events und
die dritte
fi shooter für schuhe hast ist also
dritter schuhmarke die du noch gerne an
sie sind
nein welche nike vans und trucks sharks
die ja natürlich das thema diese äußerst
fraglich wieviel pass mika habe ich
circa 23
nein als ob ich weiß jetzt zwölf sagen
ich tanze verdammt immer noch 0 0 freuen
da ist übrigens immer schon die
antworten hier hin geschrieben so tief
dass wir nicht schon mal könnten welche
wäre hier schaue ich derzeit nicht
gedacht
sebastian hat mir das vielleicht das
futter für dich wer ist mein lieblings
fenster verkehr heute sein
was war das erste projekt was wir
gemeinsam aufgenommen haben
minecraft wenig aufgenommen stifter
welche sprache spricht deutsch englisch
italienisch
und latein
das entspricht du kannst analysiert
eingeloggt nein spaß verriet die la
times klammert so landet am sonne briten
amicus diesen standard erste text ja max
was meine lieblingstiere ja ok steht 3 2
für mich jetzt jagt nächste frage an
welchem tag habe ich geburtstag
das heft ist beatles bis the job
können wir erst mal im monat an weist in
welchem monat dafür schon den punkt nach
dem krieg schmeckt nicht komplett vom 1
juni im juli
april also es gibt keinen vom november
verrät die letzte frage was sind meine
lieblingsmusik künstler also ich habe
drei stück aber du kannst du musst nur
eine raten
letzte frage wie lautet mein 28
ich weiß nicht ob du mit dem ihr schon
mal gesagt hat schon gesagt viel sagen
sebastian sebastian nachdem mein bruder
so wird ja ich weiß aber und kreativ mit
sex mit allen auf jeden fall max lappen
oder lutscher oder irgendwie so ein hey
was es gibt spezielle leonard leonard
hansen ziemlich kurz abo interessiert
mich mich bei luca vorbei wenn ihr noch
mehr von dem jet sehen wollt ich sagen
sie uns beim nächsten mal